but you know what we got here guys we
have somebody that we admire we you know
our family tiger belly is very close
families with the uh just kidding news
Bunch my brother's been there I've been
there I've been there Rosa Vaughn's been
there and I think this woman made it
happen initially because our our contact
was you and I first before I remember
like on Instagram Facebook oh yeah yeah
yeah and then you're like come on do
some videos or whatever and so I get
videos so geo Antoinette everybody give
it up lads
[Applause]
jeah what are you feeling what are you
Mexican I thought you guys were talking
about me when you guys were doing all
those acts that's why I thought you were
doing that that feels closed down but
you're a hundred percent Mexican yeah on
an honorary Asian yes because I always
thought you were Filipino because I
thought was somebody I thought you were
Mexican yeah so how did you how are you
like surrounded by so many Asians then
um I don't know it's really weird I
think I was probably Japanese or
something in my past life I'm gonna be
[ __ ] weird but yeah my mom said as a
little kid like I would turn on like
channel 18 or do we have like a local
channel 18 out here and I would just
listen to like Japanese stuff Wow I was
weird and then I mean just the area that
I grew up in was what was it home bro
Montebello Monterey Park yeah it's a lot
Asian Sarah yeah and then so you grew up
with them I did I grew up with a bunch
of Asians and I don't know they I just
never I just never thought I was my seed
and then you all you only really dated
Asian guys right yeah I had like four
series boyfriend hyah near over there
pioneer pioneer right there trailblazer
really why cuz you're a tall beautiful
curvaceous Latina
well you're a tall vivacious Latina girl
you hooked up with a bunch of Asia
what kind of Asians though one was half
white when half chinese was that the
first one yeah so you eased into it yeah
and then I got the Korean then you had a
Korean woman was that the worst one
ah I think it was the way she the family
was dope yeah but was it the worst one
yeah just used pretty shitty yeah it was
super hunk like I'm all about like Korea
this why are you dating yeah yeah okay
well that sucks
Bart Bharat so you've had three yeah
yeah Bart woody Chinese yeah Taiwanese
you Taiwanese you got to get a writer he
had to get up I don't have to get I'll
be honest with ya [ __ ] let me just say
something right now
I have to get anything right okay
bargain not afraid you're not here yeah
he's baby he doesn't care Taiwan is so
progressive
it sure is you're good with gay people
yeah the screen chewing gum the slime
for SI Singapore
no Taiwan Singapore Taiwan it's that's
why all this and that's why you're here
yeah yeah we're talking about stupidity
common sense
[Music]